Big data can come from several different
sources. One way to think about it is
whether the data was produced by a human
or whether it was produced by a machine.
Human generate a lot of data whether we
mean to or not. The first thing that I
want to talk about is intentional data. This
is the data that you know you are creating.
For instance, if you take photos, videos, or
record audio or put text on a social network,
you know you’re doing it. You can also
click “like” if you’re on Facebook.
When you do web searches, a record of the web
pages that you have viewed are bookmarked.
Your emails and your text messages. Your cell
phone calls. If you read an eBook, the highlights,
the notes in the bookmarks and online purchases.
All of these are kinds of data that do not
exist until the person deliberately makes them
happen, so these are records of human actions.
What is interesting is that, in addition to
these intentional pieces of information, there’s
also meta data. Meta data is data about data. You
might call this second order human generated data.
The idea is that, this is data that accompanies
the things that you do, and you may not be aware
of it. Interestingly, meta data can be enormous,
sometimes larger than the actual piece of data you
created. Perhaps, meta data is more significant
than the actual data for the big data world,
because it is computer generated and is
already machine readable and searchable.
Here are a few examples of meta
data and what can be done with it.
For instance, if you take a picture with
your phone, you not only get the picture,
you also get what’s called the EXIF data. That
stands for exchangeable image file format,
and this is the meta data that
comes from a picture on an iPhone.
Aside from the name of the file which you see
at the top left and that it’s 3.1 megabytes,
and the time that it was taken, near the bottom
on the right side, you can see the GPS altitude,
latitude, longitude and position, or partway
up from that, you’ll even see the GPS image
direction. It knows which way you’re holding the
camera. This is an enormous amount of information
that accompanies the photo that you get.
Another interesting thing is cell phone meta data.
There is a lot of information that accompanies
your phone call. What is interesting is that,
with just four calls where you know the time
and the position, in an anonymized data set,
that is enough information to identify
95% of individuals. Fortunately,
this information is not publicly available. But
the point here is that, it is possible to tell
a lot about people by the meta data.
Another example is email meta data.
There is a lot of information
that accompanies each email.
The four very common pieces are:
who is it from, who is it going to,
did they CC anybody, carbon copy anybody, and
the time that it was sent. Now, one really
interesting thing about this that you can do for
yourself is that MIT has created a web app called
Immersion that allows you to do a quick analysis
of your own social network via your email account.
I am going to show you the Immersion
website. It’s immersion.media.mit.edu,
and what it does is, it takes those four pieces
of information about your emails and it puts
together an image of the network. For example,
here is the Immersion demo with fictional data.
Imagine a fictionalized character, Tony
Stark. He has information six years of emails,
20,000 emails to 159 collaborators, and what you
can see is who is in his group. We have more to
Travis than anybody else. It looks like Travis
is connected with Tabitha, and you can change,
for instance, how things are distributed over
here. The number of notes that show, now we
have more and more people showing up. We can make
that a little bit smaller, and the strength of the
links between them. What is interesting is that,
for instance, when you do it to your mailbox, you
might be able to find distinct group that shows
for your family, for my job, and for people that
you socialize with. There are sometimes people
who connect several of those groups at once, but
the interesting is that, this is just based on who
you sent the email to, who it was from, the CCs,
the time and the date, and that is how it is able
to reconstruct your own personal social network.
The last thing I want to
show you is about Twitter.
Now, one of the interesting things about
Twitter is that, tweets are very small.
They are limited to 140 characters. What is
interesting about this from a research point
of view, is there is an enormous amount
of meta data that accompanies each tweet.
This image here was put together by an employee at
Twitter, Raffi Krikorian. The information in the
red is the content of the tweet. That is the stuff
that you meant to put there. But, look at all this
other information that accompanies it in terms of
whether there was a reply, a truncated version,
the author’s screen name and URL, the location,
the creation data, the account, the number of
followers, the time zone, their language, whether
they have a verified badge, the place ID, the URL,
the country, the bounding box, the application
they sent it, and etc. It is an enormous amount
of information. The meta data in this case is
several times greater than the actual content.
This is one of the most interesting things,
and this is why Twitter, in particular,
is a very rich data set for people who are doing
marketing research or social connection research.
In summary, there are all sources of big data,
and one of the interesting things about it is
that the meta data in particular, does not have
to be processed. It is already computer readable.
It is searchable. It is mineable, and
you can start to get information about
it immediately to reach your
big data analysis purposes.